[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Jade washaw Ramsey
personality is my co-host today as we
answer your questions about your life
and your money we're going to talk about
you right in front of you baby open
phones at
5225 the call is free and some say it's
worth exactly what you pay for it Kim is
with us Kim is in Asheville North
Carolina starting off this hour hi Kim
how are you hello how are you better
than I deserve what's
up okay so I have a question um we hired
a gentleman to do our taxes in March of
this year and we ended up hiring him to
do financial planning for us as well and
after hir ing him to do that we
discovered that he had filed bankruptcy
twice and had been sued for writing a
bad
check and so my question is um well he F
bankruptcy in 2019 was his last one that
was the second one and the it said the
certified financial planning board
revoked his right to use their
certification Mark H and then he also
was sued for writing a bad check to a
moving company recently
and that was um in
2018 and
so we had already paid him a large fee
to use him for financial planning and I
guess my question is should this be of
concern to
us we have discussed this with him what
did he say he says that we don't
understand what it's like to run our own
business
um and just basically was you know he
was very rude about it and said his
business would go on with or without us
o uh I want my money back I'm leaving I
don't care about the bankruptcy with
your butt I don't want to work with
you right and he you don't get to be
rude to me about this you're self you're
self you're defensive which means that
yeah I've been I've been sued and I
filed bankruptcy but if you ask me about
it I'll just tell you I almost feel like
not last week but I mean I'll just tell
you right I almost feel like you open
with that if you're if that's part of
your story
that's what's informed you to this point
he claimed that he told us in the
contract well I made him send that back
to us because it
disappeared after we signed it and we
couldn't see our own copy so he sent it
to me a couple weeks ago there was a
link that we could click in small print
about this how much did you pay this guy
$1,500 okay will he refund you or not he
will not okay I'm walking anyway I'm
walking anyway
I'm walking anyway well yeah we told him
we were walking because we don't trust
him and just because of his attitude
exactly exactly it's not the thing it's
the attitude okay because here's the
thing okay let's say the moving company
tore up 17 of his items and then they
would then they wanted to you know and
then he unpacked it and found a vase
that they were responsible for they
don't want to refund him for the broken
vase so he stops payment on the check
they sue him well that's a valid story
sure right he also he told me that he
didn't he settled that check I said well
you didn't settle it or they wouldn't
have sued you yeah well it's the
attitude is the thing it's like look hey
if I were in your here's the proper way
to answer this question if I'm him if I
were in your shoes I'd have these exact
same concerns I'm happy to tell you the
details okay here's what happened in
this situation and here's what happened
in that situation and the bankruptcy was
not you don't understand why it's like
to run a business the bankruptcy was I
did some stupid butt things I learned
from it and I'm not doing them anymore
the check was the moving company
misbehaved and I used that as leverage
and it got out of hand and they sued me
but they had no basis to judge through
it out yeah he blamed his ex-wife for
the bad check I I don't care you see
what I'm saying that if you had gone
that way then he would have redeemed his
credibility if he' had been smarter and
done what Jade said and set upfront what
was going on it's part of your story
that's fine that's fine that's what we
felt but i' I've been sued for things
that I didn't do that they made up in
effort to try to basically use the court
system to Blackmail me to settle with
them I refuse to settle with them so
that gets all in the news so you can
look up Dave Ramsey got sued but the
basis of the lawsuits are zero didn't
absolutely did not occur but it doesn't
matter you can sue somebody for anything
in America so I don't mind telling you
that that's happened okay um but but
I've still got you know I've still got
if you want to be pissed at Dave Ramsey
randomly you can find places on the
internet that I did all kinds of things
I didn't
do yeah well I you know he said he was
going to sue the certified financial
planning board for good luck with that
yeah and I was like how can you do that
yeah he just sounds a little I don't I
really don't like his attitude I don't
like that he's defensive he sounds like
he's pointing the finger blaming it
doesn't sound like it's going to be a
fun work environment for you to work
with this I'm walking away I think I
think I think you should walk away and
you already had walked away so you
already knew the answer to the question
yeah she well she probably wanted to
know if there was some way she could
force him to get the money back but I
wouldn't put any effort into it I'd just
move on I don't think you're going to
turn him into not being a jerk yeah I
think he's already got that one down
well if he hasn't done any work for them
yet in that capacity I feel like a good
person would say hey you didn't know
this we haven't started this yet here's
your money back even a not good person
knows that some customers are worth more
are more trouble than they're worth and
if I'm her and I disagree with her I
mean if I'm him and I disagree with her
she's more trouble than she's worth
here's your money back go away even if I
even even if I'm not a good person it's
just it's worth the just to get rid of
them absolutely you know we fire a
customer around here that misbehaves
ever so often they you can't call here
and cuss at our people we don't allow
you to do that yeah we'll give you your
money back tell you go away you know
that's all right I don't I don't put up
with your junk cuz some customer service
uh people in America their whole job is
to get cussed at by Rah holix all day
long ter and we don't our our customer
service people I tell them listen just
tell them no yeah we don't wait a minute
wait we don't talk like that here you're
not doing that just call somewhere else
and be pissed off take your money and
that you're going to use here and use it
for counseling you need it you know just
move on right but yeah I mean it it's
even if you're on the other side of it
it's worth it to get rid of and I don't
think Kim's that I think Kim's figured
this out um yeah the sad thing is is
that now she's questioning all Financial
people or planners yeah whether or
trustworthy I'll tell you what you know
smart Fester Pro will sit down with you
they don't charge you a thing cuz they
make a commission yep off of of uh
selling you a mutual fund for your for
your Roth IRA or your kids college fund
um and they don't make anything unless
they sell you something so people are
all suspect about that but they're the
good ones they do it with the heart of a
teacher that's why we endorse smart
Vestor Pros uh we don't have any fee
based financial planners in our system
yeah that are upfront
fees uh not because I'm mad at them they
just don't like
us because I endorse mutual funds yeah
that makes sense and um you know
because here's the thing there's a thing
in the financial world is worth talking
about this in the 20 seconds we've got
called the fiduciary and you see it on
there's there's one company running and
they're lying about it on their TV ad
during uh football I saw it last two or
three weekends I can't think what it's
called little green sign in the
background but like we are
fiduciaries we are fiduciaries we don't
make anything unless you make something
we are fidu no the word fiduciary means
a person of
trust can you trust someone that gets a
commission yes if they're
trustworthy all real estate agents are
commission-based fiduciaries and they
should put your interest first yeah they
just they but just because you get paid
when they make a sale doesn't mean you
can't have integrity that's right that's
absurd so that's the financial world
right now this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey guys I've told you before about
Christian Healthcare Ministries a health
cost sharing Ministry but listen to
Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in and an incredible way she loves that
with chm she can help other families who
need it and receive help back when her
own family has an eligible medical event
chm has been a godsend for Jenna that's
her chm story and it could be yours
learn more and join at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
coach co-host today the ramsy show
question of the day sponsored by
neighborly your hub for home services
from repairs and maintenance to
Remodeling and upgrades neighborly
trusted home service providers have
trained local experts to handle almost
any job download the neighborly app and
you can connect to all the help you need
these are great people they are today's
question of the day comes from Paula in
Georgia my son school is running a food
bank so I sent him with some highly
requested items such as peanut butter
canned soup soup and tuna fish when my
husband saw them he insisted we don't
donate quality items like these and
instead only Donate rice and beans I'm
aware that you've told people to eat
beans and rice if they're on a tight
budget and cannot afford to indulge and
nicer Foods however I also know that you
value generosity and giving and I didn't
see anything wrong with donating
something other than beans and rice do
you believe that the same principle
applied to those on a tight budget
should also be applied to recipients of
food
banks oh brother I don't mean to laugh
but it's just so silly that's silly it's
silly yeah number one when we say beans
and rice honey it's a metaphor yeah a
metaphor is a a representation
philosophically of an actual item I am
not suggesting that people only live on
beans and rice I am suggesting that you
quit spending s dad gun much money on
food especially eating out all the time
so probably prime rib is not on your
list or Lobster taale but possibly even
some Hamburger Helper might make the
list you don't have to just literally do
beans and rice it's a metaphor I think
this guy was just looking for an excuse
to be a tightwad be a che SK he didn't
have to look for an excuse he already
was I mean goodness gracious and it's
not like tuna fish is that big of an
upgrade from racing beans I mean come on
now and here's the deal I mean what
we're talking about is you limiting your
consumption so so you can create margin
yeah to move ahead we're not talking
about those poor people don't need any
good food what in the world dude
terrible
seriously seriously yeah that's horrible
yes they need some good food send them
some good food you cheap skate your wife
is right your son is even better learn
from them sir yeah oh my gosh if you're
going to give something away be generous
with what you're giving that's right hly
I'm going to give you a car but it
doesn't really run because you can just
you can figure that out for yourself
what in the world you know what Dave
though I I've I've been okay so I've
been here about 13 months 14 months I am
shocked at how many people I've
encountered that think the beans and
rice rice and beans thing is literal let
me tell you what's worse okay 30 years
of doing this I have had precisely
4732 offers to co-author a beans and
rice cookbook with other listeners
I made that up but it's close to 4,000 I
mean it's unbelievable the and
apparently it would be a best seller if
we could just get the people that wanted
to co-author it look with me to buy it
but yeah people keep asking me about it
I'm beans and rice cookbook no it's it's
a it's a metaphor a metaphor it's a
metaphor yes you can this you can eat
different food look it up look up
metaphor it's good for oh my gosh yeah
but we don't need to be going out to eat
every night it's some fancy spancy thing
or for that matter for fast food because
it's fast but it's not necessarily food
and the
um and you know you're working so that
you can learn to put yourself as a guy I
used to work for would say we're working
so I can get enough money that I can
read the menu from left to right I know
that's right I don't start with the
price I get to start with a thing and
pick what I want prices irrelevant but
when you're broke you self-manage your
consumption not other people imposing on
you yeah their their beans and rice so
oh my gosh yeah then you're entering
into like a judgment kind of Zone I
think and it's like well just be
generous if you can yeah I mean I yeah
you you kind of missed the point sir
yeah kind of not kind of you did all
right Aya is with us aa's in Washington
DC hi Aya what's up hi Mr Ramsey hey um
I was wondering if we should pay off our
current mortgage and relocate for a
current cheaper
mortgage what's making you ask that
question wait pay off your current
mortgage or
relocate and get a cheaper mortgage what
would be cheaper than a paid off
mortgage um so we bought a house that
needed to be fixed up so we fixed it up
and now it's we just had a realer come
out and tell us what we could list it as
my husband was in the military and just
got out and his job fell through so it
kind of shook us and we just wanted to
move somewhere with the proceeds to have
a cheap enough mortgage to be covered by
my
disability okay um so you're not you
don't have the opportunity to pay off
your mortgage you're talking about
moving to a less expensive property
because you're scared about his
income right why do you think he's not
going to get an
income um it's not so much that he
wouldn't get one we're just um kind of
thinking about we prioritizing our time
the house that we bought is a historic
house so it takes a lot of Maintenance
we do a lot of the work
ourselves that's a different discussion
what do you owe on that house
uh 490 490,000 I already don't like the
house I hate that we have spent so much
time on it we can get some good money
for it and get something I like is a
good reasonable move I'm using his lack
of a job and a cheaper mortgage as my
excuse is not
okay okay um you see the difference
we're just kind of we're both yeah we're
both on the same boat so we're just you
know the boat where he doesn't
work
just that he has more
flexibility and we're
not how old is he not right now how old
is he we're 25 and 26 okay he needs to
get a career
darling it's not good for him to not
work much I'm not saying he won't work I
am saying he needs to get a career where
he
works okay I'm hearing the code words in
your language 100% he's not to work much
at all and that's worrying part of it is
he got knocked out of the saddle and
didn't get the other job and it's he's
lost some of his confidence and you're
clearly worried because you're talking
about selling your house and relocating
so that you could only live on your
disability like you said it with your
own
words I don't think that that came out
right we he wants to work that's not the
issue the issue is is that we want to be
more flexible with not having to deal
with the house and not having a mortgage
that's so high is the mortgage than 25%
of your take-home pay it is now that
he's not working but before that was it
no no it wasn't okay okay so your
mortgage amount is not your problem the
house if you want to get rid of a house
that's a money pit where you work on it
all the time I don't blame you I would
do that okay but let let's not couch
that in he wants more flexibility and
when I'm talking about his job your
answer is he wants more flexibility it
wasn't when I was talking about the
house repairs you said that so I didn't
didn't misunderstand you you said it
real clearly so what what we need to do
let's let's parse this out and break it
up number one the two of you need to get
really good cool strong careers that
you're passionate about I will send you
a copy of Ken Coleman's book from
paycheck to purpose number two it
doesn't sound like your mortgage is off
me neither and I'm I'm actually
wondering number three I would sell a
house it's a money pit and I had to
screw with it all the time it drive me
nuts that's true but I don't know that
if it's a money pit that's one thing but
I don't know I'd Beed to know more she's
in Washington DC where does she plan on
relocating where she's going to they may
be move into a whole different city too
that's possible but yeah which would be
less expensive for sure yeah I'm getting
rid of The Money Pit but I'm also
getting a career yeah they need and
probably get in the house about the same
price range that in The Money Pit M when
I make the move that's would be my
advice to you guys don't don't mix these
things together and create some kind of
false narrative that's not really going
on okay that's what I heard heard you
saying I think you were saying it
whether you wanted to or not this is the
ramsy
[Music]
[Laughter]
show
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Churchill gives you
an advantage over those other guys go to
Churchill mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
[Applause]
more
in the lobby of ramsy Solutions on the
debt free stage Christina is with us hi
Christina how are you hi good welcome
nervous oh yeah you're okay we've never
lost a patient that's right you're going
to be all right we're proud of you so
you're here to do a Deb free scream
where do you live Clarksville Tennessee
Clarksville military family um I used to
be in the military but I'm not now okay
well thank you for serving a lot of a
lot of military in Clarksville that's
what I was asking yes all right and uh
how much debt did Christina from
Clarksville pay off $ 34,1 162 you're
amazing how long did this take 36 months
good for you th000 bucks a month get it
and your range of income during that
three years
$4,490 a year to
$49,500 on your house cleaning business
well
so um my business started 8 years ago um
but um my journey um officially started
I went through my first FPU class in
2012 so I've been doing this for a long
time um I was married at the time and
we tried to get on the same page and and
um couldn't couldn't and it took a lot
of years to figure out that we couldn't
so in 2020 of uh April of 20 my divorce
was filed oh my gosh what a year yeah
and the next month my business closed
because you know nobody wants us in our
home when everybody has Co that's right
oh wow so I started off my journey um in
the basement of a friend of a friend's
house with not much money and uh not
really sure what was going to happen and
so since then um start cleaning houses
again yeah started clean and the nice
thing about Co is everybody wanted their
houses clean once we got that started
going again so so we uh we actually got
got that back up and going and now um
now you're making 50 Grand that's a
killer well well that's everything
included that's that's um child support
and everything but it it that's quite a
journey yeah good for you you get after
it girl way that's incredible you got to
feel like your your whole life has
transformed in 36 months yeah it has
it's a whole different world yeah I mean
career marital status confidence
everything thing wow you're oh and you
got out of debt I got out of debt yeah
you're amazing I'm so proud of you it's
it's not me it's all it's all God yeah
well he he was actually using you to
clean those toilets I know that's right
you you put you put in the work I did do
that
yeah you got to plant that corner it
doesn't grow as you so so you reap way
to go kiddo very proud of you excellent
all right so uh what kind of debt was
$34,000 oh it was everything it was a it
was back taxes it was uh back rent um
just from after the divorce it was um
student loan car loan um how' you get
all the debt you got all the debt from
the divorce um no I got a I got a little
just just over half of it uh but that
was my half that was my half of
everything okay so the back rent was
both of you and then you got half the
back rent M okay I love the support I'm
seeing from your son that that is that's
hitting me man I love it you you
definitely clearly had the support of
your family next to you I do that's the
only reason that I got here is because
of all the support uh it's one thing to
have two teenagers it's another to have
two good on I mean yes what yeah where
it go she's like what me yes
you amazing amazing wow well you know
they they've been with me the whole time
I mean right after right after um um
when we started cleaning again and and
things were starting to move along I
actually tried to homeschool them cuz
that was smart on top of everything I
had to deal with I thought that
homeschooling them was going to be a
good plan so for that first year after
Co we homeschooled for a year and and
and every month every month for um our
finance lesson I bought the the Ramsey
home school thing and everything and
every month for our we came up here we
came up here to watch your show and I
brought my planner and I would do my
budget at the end of the month right
here in the lobby and then whoever was
doing the show I had sign sign my
planner for that month so yall were kind
of my account ability for that first
month while I was trying to get back on
my feet wow wow you're my accountability
CU they keep coming to work you're
inspiring very inspir so they've been
with me they they've come along with me
on everything this year when when I
finally got in a head space to where I
could really buckle down um we I brought
them to the Building Wealth live um I
came to the smart conference I brought
them with me to meet micro for the labor
crisis so they've been drug along with
like everything so wow they're my little
buddies I love it I love it so what's
next building up the emergency fund
feeling good about the future how does
it feel to have no
debt Sur Real I mean I've been trying
since 2012 and and I i' I listen to
these all the time I've come see I've
come seen your shows I mean for years
and I I cry every time that I I watch
one and I just never imagined I would
actually be up here okay so you overcome
living in a friend of a friend's
basement you overcome the business
closing down and opening up you overcome
$34,000 wor of debt you overcome the
loss of your marriage all in the last 36
months you truly are a warrior princess
you're amazing I mean that's powerful
really is I feel like a lot of it was I
don't think it was because of me I think
it I feel like most time it was in spite
of me cuz no you're a hero you're a hero
you need to own it yeah you do you
committed to for some people it really
is a longer journey and you committed
for the whole journey
it's just like your shirt anybody who
can't read her shirt everything is
possible for the one who believes and
that is such I mean you're really
evidence of that you kept belief and you
kept going and you got knocked down and
you kept going and you got knocked down
again and you kept going and here you
are on the stage yeah but I'm
hard-headed too I actually called in Ken
show about six years ago to ask if I
should try to pay off debt or hire some
people for my business and he said that
you get what you focus on so I should
pay off debt so I went and I hired a
bunch of people and
that's
hilarious so so you know and then and
then I remember I remember um I remember
the back when y'all were in your old
building uh I got I I really I was I got
my husband got me my ex-husband got me a
a car for in 2018 for my birthday and I
had a paid off van and I was listening
to I listen to you guys in a red all I
got all your books and I I've been
trying for a long time you know and uh I
got that and and part of me was like you
can't take this and then part of me was
like well it was a gift and her marriage
wasn't doing well so this is kind of fun
so well we'll see I felt so guilty
taking that car that the next day I
drove out to your old place in
Brentwood to get a lecture from you on
why I shouldn't have a car payment and I
felt so as I felt but I left I left the
office that morning and Nicole my office
manager she said so you going to tell
Dave that uh you're you're you're there
in your new car and I said absolutely
not and I said in fact I was so ashamed
that I parked across the street at the
stores and I walked over so that I
didn't have to park in your parking lot
wow you didn't defile the parking lot I
did not defile the parking lot and I I
cannot tell you when I got here this
morning and I was driving out here and
my my my financial coach Andy he took a
picture of my parking spot where you
have the name of all the debt free
screams and like it like just kind of
blew me away like 5 years ago I was
hiding in the bushes and now you now you
have a parking spot of Honor look at
that you don't have to park across the
street at the store in the parking spot
of Shame that's right that's right I
have a car that you can't open the door
from the outside but that's okay that's
only temporary that's only temporary how
old how old are your your kiddos
um 16 and 14 16 and 14 and their names
uh his is Grace and Christian Grace and
Christian well go well done mom well
done I know you're nervous but um we're
pretty impressed you you we run into a
lot of people on this stage and some of
them are Overcomers some of them knock a
few things down uh you you you just took
a machete and whacked your way through
the jungle kiddo pretty amazing pretty
amazing well done hey we've got the live
and give box for you that includes The
Total Money Makeover book The Baby Steps
millionaires book because that's your
destiny and uh no stopping this one woo
and a Financial Peace University
membership and you guys are incredible
uh Grace and Christian I I know you know
this but your mom is a superhero very
cool all right count it down you guys
34,000 paid off in 36 months from 15,000
to 49 count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three two one we're debt
[Music]
free wow goodness
woo allergies are bad this season I'm
just saying that'll make your eyes water
right there that's the Ramsey
[Music]
show if you're like most people your
home is your most valuable asset and
when you want to make improvements it
can feel like everything costs too much
or takes too long but something as
simple as custom window coverings from
blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees every
things backed by their 100% satisfaction
guarantee and shipping is always free
see why blinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com and get up to
35% off that's blinds.com to learn more
rules and restrictions May
[Music]
apply
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
88255 225 well in case you wondered if
smart conference that you did on the
hill up here was important last caller
told us it was or one of the other
streaming events or one of the other 9
million things we do around here like
I'm doing a show every day and you can
come in here and watch the show live is
important we had no idea she'd been in
here all those times that's right it
first time we ever met her MH so very
very interesting stuff very interesting
stuff speaking of starting your journey
uh Jade washaw will be doing a free
every dooll webinar at everydollar.com
budgeting you can sign up up and help
you break the cycle of living paycheck
to paycheck when is the webinar tomorrow
tomorrow at 11:30 central time so sign
up so like Tuesday the 10th yep Tuesday
the 10th Tuesday the 10th at 11:30 a.m.
Central Time if you're not able to do
that or you hear this at a later date
because you catch it on your podcast or
YouTube or something at a later date
there are others so be sure to go to
everydollar.com budgeting Jade will be
doing more Rachel Cruz will be doing
more and George will be doing more of
these uh budgeting webinars and they
actually make budgeting fun they
actually help you work out how to take
your paychecks and pick out which thing
goes in which thing we call it paycheck
planning through the month so every
dollar has an assignment for that matter
every dollar of every check has an
assignment when you're done uh it's a
very usable very friendly world's best
budgeting app and by the way we're not
charging you this free totally free
every dollar webinar every
.com/srobiyt
no he passed in June but we he passed
two months after we bought the house oh
I'm so sorry how old was he 53 oh I'm
sorry young what happened yeah um well
long story short and stayed River
failure oh my I'm so sorry W how long
were youall married um 14 years okay how
old and you're about the same age I'm 47
47 okay all right how can we help today
I'm so sorry so thank you so anyway like
I said this is the first home I've ever
owned and I'm trying to figure out
everything on my own and it just so
happened that the neighbor that we share
a fence line with and there is just one
fence line the fence line fell into my
property and I was hoping that the
homeowner adjacent would go half and
half on replacing the fence but they
don't seem interested in that so I guess
I'm stuck with fixing the fence by
myself okay um well typically the fence
is put up just inside the property line
of one party or the other okay so if the
survey was done the fence posts would
typically be on your property or on
their property meaning that it's either
your fence or their
fence okay the posts were definitely on
their property okay so it's definitely
their fence fix I guess so now that you
explained it yeah yeah and so um you
know now uh did something knock it down
or it just rotted down or what just yeah
just rotted and it was the wind but we
both have dogs so I feel somewhat
responsible to get it fixed as opposed
to what you know it just being an issue
you know so I just didn't know what the
recourse if there is any or if I just
need to fix it because they won't did
when you brought it to them they were
probably unaware of whose property it
was on do you think that if you let them
know hey it's on your property do you
think that would change it at all or is
it just a situation where they're not
spending money on that yeah I can try
now that you told me that because I
wasn't sure you know I just didn't know
so if I if I the fence posts are on your
property so this is your fence I will go
in with you to help you fix your
fence oh you know what that sounds a lot
Kinder but I sentence can we split this
that's a different sentence if you cuz
they're be the owner of the fence when
it's fixed M and you're just doing that
out of the goodness of you're doing that
to keep your dogs out of their yard
absolutely and their dogs out of mine
but I didn't know that and I wasn't
armed with that so maybe I'll try that
and see what happens I appreciate it
yeah I don't know my guess is they don't
have the money yeah so none of this
might change it it might also might help
to this is what I would do I might have
someone come look at it so I had some
actual numbers to say hey oh sure I was
looking at this if we both chip in you
know $600 I don't know how what that
cost if we both chip in $600 they'll
come out and fix it I know you know and
tell them it's on their side hey I I
took I looked at the parameters it's
technically your fence but it benefits
both of us if you chip in 600 I'll chip
in 600 you know I already found a guy
will fix your fence yeah that sounds
reasonable I like that thank you very
much I didn't even think about that yeah
how how how big a piece of property are
we dealing
with how long how many how many how long
is the section of fences down 50 ft 500
guess it's like I don't know it's like
eight panels so I I'm not really good
that okay so it's like a privacy
fence correct yes okay all right well
we're not talking a lot of money here
then well that's good I was just didn't
know if I had any recourse to action but
I like what you said I don't think you
have any recourse I think you've got
persuasion and neighborly love and those
kinds of things because here's the
problem if you put up a fence just
inside your property they can attach to
it and still get the benefit of it MH
exactly but you know and put no money in
yeah worse comes to worse I'll do that
but I like your way better I'll at least
try it yeah thanks and you know the
other thing I would
do and this sounds manipulative but it's
not because it's the truth I would just
you're a I would sit down in front of
them personally if you can do they live
there no it's just ENT at the property
that's part of the problem that's why
they don't care it's part of the problem
too okay oh no not them in particular
they they've but they have the renters
have dogs that come in your yard yes
because the owner has not fixed his
fence this is a problem now it's
different correct yeah anyway do do the
people do you know the people that own
it no no not personally do they happen
to live in your area or do you know I
don't know that okay if you can find out
it's always better to talk about things
in person okay always better because and
if you can do that number one number two
I would tell them your story and your
story is hey I've never done anything
like this because I've never owned real
estate my husband died right after we
moved in here and I don't know how to
navigate this stuff so um I don't even
know if I could do that frankly I could
barely do it with you guys well if you
did it with us you can do it with them
yeah I suppose yeah you can do it 24
million people just listened in on this
conversation so that's right imagine you
can have a one duper over a cup of
coffee all right so uh but yeah just
just sit down and go look I lost my
husband in June and I don't know how to
do all this stuff but here's an idea I
had your your your renter's dogs are
getting in my yard my dogs are getting
in your yard and and the fence is on
your property so it's your fence but
I'll chip in with you on your fence I
got some bids like Jade said it's 400
bucks I'll put in 200 if you guys will
put in 200 would you would you help out
help out a neighbor here and let's get
this fixed up yeah and you know it's
hard to turn that one down and it's also
worth mentioning that you're trying to
avoid something bigger cuz if you guys'
dogs get to fighting if somebody's dog
bites in NE like I can just see this
snowballing into a bigger issue and if
the owner is going to want to avoid that
at all cost if they know what's going on
well you know what I'm saying because
one more one more word to have one more
reason to not have uh Runners with dogs
but what do I know so I love dogs love
dogs me and my dog spent time together
this morning right before I came to work
but uh none but I hate dogs as a
landlord so as a we don't have any we
don't have any Ramsey houses with dogs
in them not not legally anyway there
might be some illegal aliens but not not
legally so illegal alien dogs yeah yeah
Dave have a heart people they got to
bring their they can't bring their pet I
know they the problem is they don't make
them behave just like some people's
children right that's right and then I
got a house is all torn up because I
didn't have a backbone but anyway that's
what's happening so there you go there
you go and then the fence falls down
that's right dog knocked it down I know
what
happened this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show hey what's up guys it's Jade look
if you like what you heard in this
episode and want to know more about
getting started on the Ramsey Baby Steps
go to Ramsey solutions.com and click the
get started button we'll help you figure
out the best next step for you based on
your specific situation that's Ramy
solutions.com and click get
[Music]
started
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships thank you for joining us
America open phones at
88255 225 you jump in we'll talk about
your life and your money Jade washaw
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
thank you for joining us again triple 8
5225 Mark starts off this hour in
Springfield Missouri hey Mark welcome to
the Ramsey Show hey Dave um I got a
question I know how the baby steps work
but I'm i' I've got a little bit of a
quandry as to where I need to put my
wife's student loans in this because she
is still in school and not having to pay
on them so do I put them in because
she's got 12 loans do I put them in
where they go and slow my snowball down
or do I put them at the end and continue
my snowball until I get to them I'd put
them in where they go she's got 12 of
them so I'd list i' I'd put those in
smallest to largest along with your
other debts and you might have one
student loan and then a credit card and
then a student loan and then a car
payment and then you know it doesn't all
have to be by group and I think
sometimes in our minds we want it to be
that way but that's okay just put them
in as they go smallest to largest how
much student loan debt is there
it's 58,000 and how much other data is
there uh there's two cars um one is
9,000 and one is
13,000 and the student loans only one of
them is more than the first car so I'm
going to be paying we're going to be
doing like 11 student loans and then a
car yeah it's
46,000 that I'm not going to be building
what's your household yeah you won't be
building any sing because you payments
on those to cancel out I got you that's
a good point um so the uh what's your
income the household income is 170,000
and when does she
graduate uh she'll graduate um she she's
doing part-time schooling so she's got
uh I think six semesters left and we can
have both of the cars paid off before
that are they are they subsidized or are
they unsubsidized she's got two that are
getting taxes not taxes uh interest yeah
and the rest of them aren't um say uh 58
and 46
right you said 58,000 student loan debt
and how much other yeah and then uh
9,000 on one car and 13 on another oh
okay so 31 and
58 right so 808 89,000 L than that no
we're at 880,000 we're right at 880,000
M yeah okay all right 79,000 I added it
wrong okay um and you make
170,000 yes okay explain to me why you
can't pay all this in a
year because we have eight
kids wow they don't eat that much you
can raise eight kids on 100
Grand well we the the eight kids are are
all teenagers you can raise eight kids
on 100 Grand man there's Sports there's
food there's all that stuff it's just
it's a year of
sacrifice yeah um because it
170 minus 79 is one year you're debt
free I mean if you can't do it in a year
you'll be able do it in 14 months uh I
think you're looking you know when you
said she's going to be six semesters and
you're just going to barely have two
cars paid off you're not making any
progress
no we'll we'll have we'll have the two
cars paid off by August of next year
yeah you ought to have you ought to be
done by August of next year the whole
stinking thing are close so are you
paying cash for her College as she goes
yes we we have stopped with the student
loans we are paying cash for everything
now good and what is she
studying uh she's getting her master's
and uh
business like it's not the MBA but it's
it's a a business okay and and her
intention is to do what with her career
with eight kids uh to help me run my
business I see okay while you have eight
kids yes that are teenagers okay yes all
right yeah good well you're doing well
with your business sir is the 170,000
taxable net profit on your business or
is that your gross
revenues the the 100 100 of it is from
my business that's the uh the taxes and
everything no that's before taxes and
everything before before
expenses yes what do you take home from
the business as
payment um well I've been taking home uh
just
$800 a week now what are you pay in
taxes on on the $100,000 of Revenue that
this business creates you do not have a
household income of 170 that's why you
couldn't see doing this because you
don't have a net profit of 100,000 on
the business that's your gross revenues
okay yeah I'm not sure what it will be
this year because I I didn't make this
much last year so you make last year
last year last year I only made 50,000
gross gross yeah did you net anything on
that um not much we we still with the
money that she paid in for her taxes we
still got a tax return
so and we have we have fixed that I know
that you don't like to hear tax so we
fixed that honey I'm still trying to
figure out if your business is making a
profit you you know what a profit is yes
I know what a profit is it's your
taxable income on the
business yes on $50,000 did you have to
pay any
taxes no because then you lost money on
$50,000 worth of Revenue with with what
my wife paid in on on her check well
here's what you your wife your wife
check's got nothing to do with your
business's profitability you need to
hire someone to run your books yeah you
need you need to sit down with a
bookkeeper and learn how to do a set of
books that's the next you you don't even
have any idea if you're making a
profit because a profit is your gross
revenues minus the expenses associated
with the business equals profit and I'm
not sure you made a profit on 50 Grand
so I'm not sure you're making a profit
on 100 Grand thus I think you're trying
to raise kids on 70
grand actual Revenue which is your your
actual other income not business related
income and yeah you're not going to pay
it off in a year doing that so we need
to figure out out whether this
calculations right to tell you if my
advice was bogus but I had bad
information from you m even still
they're still going to have to walk
through a debt snowball and if the
business is not making money they're
going to have to find more money coming
in yeah in order to make this happen
fast with eight kids you need to quit
running getting a master's degree to run
a business it is profit not making money
yeah that's that's losing money at that
point yeah it's already losing money
probably I can't tell can't tell cuz he
doesn't know but anyway yeah get to the
bottom of figure out if you're making a
profit or not and if you're expanding
that cuz you definitely increased your
revenues but I'm not sure you increased
your profits cuz if you lose 25 cents of
watermelon you don't just get a bigger
truck that's not how this works so
um all right uh then based on all of
that what would I do yeah I might pay
off the car first and let the student
loans set to the side for a minute at
least get rid of one of the dad gun
payments out of your type budget but I I
can't tell what your budget is so it's
really hard to tell you if it's worth
doing that if you truly made a profit of
100,000 which I think we've established
you didn't um then you had $170,000
actual household income then I would go
back to my original thing and say shut
up and pay off the loans in a year or 14
months if 79,000 should go away but I
don't think that's the numbers so I
think it changed in the middle of the
conversation it did this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lumpsum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y refi.com
[Music]
Ramsey
Jade washaw Ramsey personality open
phones at
5225 Jade is my co-host today by the way
folks uh I do a show called The entree
leadership podcast where I take calls on
small business and we talk about the
five stages of business and what it
takes to level up in those five stages
the six drivers that do that we've got a
whole system for teaching small
businesses to grow and run it's the
Playbook the book entree leadership is a
number one best seller it's the Playbook
that we've used to run Ramsey and we've
grown it in 30 years from a card table
in my living room to about a $300
million company so we'll walk you
through this stuff and when you're at
that beginning stage is a called a
treadmill operator when it's just you
and all the revenue and all the
production counts on you you kind of
just own your job at that point when
you're a small business person and
you're doing doing all the work and um
you know and the revenue comes in
because of you the production comes in
because of you all that kind of stuff
it's a one or two maybe a three-man lady
show whatever there uh that's the normal
way everyone starts but those are the
stages that you have to get things in
place like a good set of accounting
books a good set of books uh to where
you know what's happening with your
money if you do not make the money
behave and those of you in the
construction world the remodeling world
you do job costing and you know which
each job is profitable so you learn to
do your estimating properly you you know
you set up you know can I afford to hire
someone well you have to can I afford to
buy a piece of equipment or can I afford
to rent another space uh you have to be
able to take look at your numbers and
see if you have a profit to be able to
do that because a business that doesn't
make a profit is called a hobby it's
kind of a harsh hobby actually cuz
you're delusional and I've done it
accidentally a time or two are do you
run a nod for profit not intentionally
but there's a time or two that I almost
have yeah so uh but yeah that's a uh you
know so if you want to learn more onree
leadership is the is one of the top
business and Leadership podcasts out
there you can join me I do it once a
week and it's on the Ramsey networks and
we would love to have you join us and
check out the whole entree leadership
brand we've got events you can come to
uh we've got a whole uh subscription
process where we coach you called Elite
and so all of that falls into that
bucket for that our last caller uh Jeff
is in Cleveland Ohio hi Jeff welcome to
the Ramsey show Hello thank you very
much for taking my call I really
appreciate it sure what's up um I'm 52
years old my wife is 51 and a couple
years ago she was diagnosed with a form
of
dementia um so we are TR navigating that
um as far as our financials go we have a
will a financial power of attorney
healthc care power attorney a living
will in place
good um she's no longer on the de of the
house but she has lifetime access to the
residence through the will um she has no
property or any bank accounts in her
name at all we have our six month
emergency fund why did you take
everything out of her name uh that's
what the attorney had said for what I I
uh because she because she might misuse
them if she if her dementia is
Advanced uh it might be for medicare or
Medicare I'm not sure Medicaid is for
poor people that's
welfare yeah it only works no that won't
work okay um okay and so you were doing
real good you got all the documentation
in place and uh how much do you have in
Investments uh as far as uh our Roth we
have 340 and as far as my workplace 401K
of
95,000 um within the last couple months
probably maybe three months uh I stopped
contributing to my 401k and my RW so I
could pile up money and a couple weeks
ago I paid off my house good for you
really really good so we're so we're on
step seven um which kind of brings me to
my question um with Ohio and
Medicaid uh the spouse can have up to
$140,000 in
assets except if you put the Roth IRAs
in payout status in an rmd payout status
those are not counted as
assets so hey Hey heyy listen yeah
um you're you're trying to figure out a
way to put your white you didn't mean to
but you're trying to figure out a way to
put your wife in a welfare nursing
home oh Medicaid Medicaid is Medicaid is
welfare you don't want to for po it's
for poor people and you don't need to do
that okay and and the guidelines are
there to keep it from people that are
only poor people putting people in those
nursing homes okay okay and you're not
poor people you can take care of your
wife man I'm so sorry you're facing this
but you've done a great job with money
and you're in a position to love your
wife well yeah yeah um just want to get
everything that I can out of the way so
I know but but but the the goal the goal
is to take care of her the goal is not
to put her in a Medicaid nursing home
right right let's change let's change
the goal and you evidently make good
money what do you make uh I make about
73 a year you've done a really good job
on 73 dude is she still working oh no
she she's on uh Medicare she's not able
to work or drive no okay so it's
advancing
then yeah I'm so sorry I'm sorry man
that's tough so where where are we today
does she know everyone still or what how
far progress
um we have uh we have appointments every
six months uh last appointment
you know the doctor was able to notice
some decline uh she'll go through some
more testing in another six months um
but she is able you know she is at home
um she knows you oh yeah yeah okay do
you not but you're but you're noticing
deterioration you know it varies some
days are better than others always yeah
yeah all right
um okay you're you're right to do what
you've done every single thing you've
done I agree with I think you've done a
wonderful job sir you're a good man okay
and I and I would I would agree with
your last part of your financial moves
to pile up cash and pile up cash and
pile up cash and the next stage that is
fairly inexpensive compared to nursing
home is in home
care yeah okay and so if you can pile up
another hundred grand before you need in
home care you probably have that
earmarked then to take care of her for
uh to pay for you know a nurse or help
of some kind uh of some level of
professional to come in and help you and
there may be a few days at the end of
life that that she will have to have
care there Beyond in home but maybe not
maybe not um I can tell you this okay
Sharon and I have got U we're
multi-millionaires and so I'm 63 I do
not have nursing home insurance I'm a
multi-millionaire I I will be at
home I can afford full-time care for my
wife if something happens to her and you
can too because you've done such a good
job um but you're catching it way
earlier but I mean by the time if
something happens to Sharon and she's at
home I can provide all the services of a
nursing home privately with a private
freaking Butler okay and it's still less
expensive than a nursing home mhm but
I've just got that option and you've
just about got yourself in that position
and in a very heartbreaking situation
you have been very um intentional and
wise I'm so proud of you well thank you
i' I've just followed your principles
well you you you You' had a you had an
extra
um grenade thrown in the middle of it
and so uh and it throws you off kilter
but you you know only if you are
completely broke if listen if you go
visit a Medicaid nursing home and you go
visit a private Care Nursing Home that
you pay for you'll see what I'm talking
about okay there there are a few of them
that are excellent but it's government
housing yeah versus private
residence okay that's the I mean it it's
it's it's welfare it's what for it's
okay I'm not mad I'm not talking down my
nose at somebody or something like that
but if you've got the means your job is
not to try to to dodge using your money
your job is to use your money because
that's what is forced to take care of
her yeah I think he's done a great job
job wow in it's such a difficult
situation they're they're so young early
50s man that's tough yeah and early
onset has a long lifespan it does so um
potten potentially so um yeah this could
be a decade yeah but thankfully he did
set himself up paid for mortgage he's
been investing he couldn't have done any
better very wise very wise
heartbreaking this is the ramsy show
[Music]
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsy
solutions you can drop in and have free
homemade chocolate chip cookies and
coffee anytime want we do this show from
1: to 4: central Time Monday through
Friday it's completely free to come in
and watch ugly paint dry on the wall no
we're here it's fine it's fine very
we're very entertaining so you don't
want to miss it there's always 50 to 200
folks sitting out here there's a museum
or whatever you call it a timeline of
the everything that's happened around
here it's fun to visit the lobby and
have an experience as a part of your
Nashville visit we'd love to have you in
the lobby also is a stage right in front
of our windows we call it the debt free
stage on on it is David and Lisa hey
guys how are you good how are you better
than I deserve welcome where do you live
we live in Austin area little town
called Liberty Hill oh yeah fun welcome
to Nashville good to have you guys so
how much debt have you paid off paid off
almost $300,000 or right at
$300,000 wow good for you and how long
did that take real slow five years ago
took about five years to get rid of it
and your range of income during that
time uh we started at
125,000 and we ended last year at 360
wow what do yall do for a living uh my
wife is retired now those the agreement
of paying off the house hey but um I do
s I'm 100% commission salesperson in the
hbac industry my commercial hbac oh yeah
way to go man amazing so your house is
gone and paid off house is gone and paid
off we looking at weird
people wow what's the house worth um 500
all nice how much is in your
Investments uh the last year has hurt us
a little bit but right around 400 so
you're right out a million yeah we're
right there way to go baby steps
millionaires paid for house how old are
you I'm 41 I'm 42 all right that feels
good yeah how's it feel to not have a
payment in the world nice it's nice it
definitely feels special so we feel like
we've been blessed and we don't feel
like we deserve what we have well you do
deserve it but we're better than we
deserve yeah there we go wow so was it
only the house or was there other debt
included in the 300,000 we had 242,000
on the house and then we had about
50,000 in cars and then we had crit the
rest was credit cards so we did the
credit card we did the snowball got
credit cards first and then we actually
we traded some cars we did some things
to get rid of that debt and then and
then we just worked on the house um we
actually paid 192,000 in the last 16
months wow You' been making serious
money Lisa what did you do before you
retired I've worked as a receptionist I
worked as a school as a par professional
for 5 years okay and you said I'm in but
when we're done I'm done yes yes I'm not
mad at that I like it yeah want to focus
on our daughter Claire who's here with
us to today and well it gives you a
reason to push forward like that that's
excellent now you got now you're just an
old retired person at 42 had your reward
at the end I love
that yeah so what else are you planning
to do I mean you've got you don't have a
payment in the world is there a trip is
there something fun that you're going to
do to celebrate this is kind of our trip
we kind of no you got to do better than
that we got we we got was cool but you
got to do better well we we came in s
Saturday to do this and then we're going
to go to Nashville till next weekend
this was kind of our whole like we
wanted to do this I've been a couple of
times on business but they've never been
so it's something that we wanted to do
together oh we love the area so we're
going to we're going to head into
Nashville tonight and stay till Saturday
yep oh good that's fun you'll have a
blast you'll have a blast thank you guys
no we appreciate you I mean like I said
we uh one of the things that we find
interesting is I have a degree in
history and I fell into hbac and just
never got out and we feel like God has a
plan for us because we should never have
done what we've done not with uh I
wanted to be a teacher and never got to
do it so I uh fell into HVAC sales and
never got out so but they all you know
doesn't always work out the way we plan
so okay so how did you originally get
connected with us in this
process um I've done FPU through church
a few times and we taught it once at our
house during covid and everything and we
saw you when you came to Austin couple
years ago you come Austin a couple times
actually I have a constant reminder of a
key chain with your
yeah yeah live like no one else yeah so
we have a constant reminder um but it's
something that you know we've we've
supported and we love and yeah we have
family that my dad you know we grew up
like in debt all the time and my dad's
running the program now we're running
the program my brother just sold some
houses to pay off his debt and get stuff
so we've got the family is in a better
place because you know we're all
following you now changing your family
tree absolutely all the
limbs that's what we're trying to we're
trying to do lead by example right yeah
well done very well done what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
Deb is I mean you're debt free in your
40s house and everything baby steps
millionaires pretty impressive just
commitment being on the same page you
know we've sacrificed a lot and said no
to a lot of things but what was the
deepest cut on the sacrifice the thing
you remember that was the biggest
ouchie I mean probably vacations just
and family stuff we used to do a lot of
Barbecues in the summer times and during
football season where we'd have people
and we kind of just cut it all off CU it
got real expensive oh yeah you know
doing it every weekend it starts up real
fast so we we made a lot of sacrifices
where we were those crazy people where
we just weren't doing a lot of fun and
we were trying to do little day trips
here in there instead of like big
vacations and we we've become
professionals at having breakfast for
dinner at least twice a week and we've
continued that so I was going to say
breakfast for dinner is that really a
sacrifice cuz that's that's legitimate
it's a sacrifice for them now but now
all now all that stops no we well no I
mean I mean if you want to do it you can
do it but the breakfast on your I mean
it says on your keychain live like no
one else so later you can live like no
one else and give like no one else want
you to enjoy this now yeah and we plan
to and it's it's just something that's
hard to break when you've been doing it
for five years I know but it's football
season dude get the barbecue going get
the barbecue going man get it back going
again it's time you did you did a good
job You've Won you sacrificed to win now
enjoy the winnings that's right well
done proud of you guys very good what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of debt is you told me that right you
said commitment and sacrifice but I
didn't let I didn't let David answer
yeah so the hardest thing for me is
finding contentment I know Rachel talks
about it all the time and my wife tells
me all the time it's just finding we
we've worked together really well but
the budget is the biggest thing um you
always say to let the other person you
know I'm the one that controls the
budget but I've always given her you
know she's always looked it over and
made some change I forced her to make a
change every single time so that she was
committed to the process good um but
working together through the whole thing
I mean I couldn't have done it without
them I mean the process of you know I
kind of bribed her a little bit with the
retirement thing as soon as we get it
done you can retire but in reality I
think she just gave you her terms yes
well I don't think you bried her at all
this is this is what it takes to get me
in yeah this is what it takes to get
where we want to be so good we're
excited about it Go terms of surrender
well done very well done all right you
guys excellent job hey we've got the
live and give box for you uh the baby
steps millionaires you made it there or
almost so close we're calling it and
depending on whether the market goes up
today or tomorrow there you go and a
Total Money Makeover book to give away
to someone and a Financial Peace
University membership to give away while
you're continuing to lead classes thank
you for leading the classes it makes a
big difference people go to those
classes as you know their life gets
changed yeah and uh you got it's because
of people like you coordinating so thank
you for being a coordinator we really
really appreciate it and you're a
perfect example too I know right we
appreciate everything you do yes well
God bless y'all all right David and Lisa
and Claire Austin Texas area 300,000
paid off house and
everything weird people baby steps
millionaires did it in 5 years making
125 up to now 360 count it down let's
hear a debt free Scream 3 2 1 we're debt
free
yeah 11 it
yes man oh man oh
man hey those two leaned in they sure
did pretty incredible the whole family
that's that's that's well done well
played this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
d Wasa Ramsey personality is
my co-host Today podcast
reviews five stars the J rant on the
student loans was powerful she really
painted the depth of the problem and the
hurt that can come from them the best
rant I've heard in months it should be
required listening to every semester of
high school and college way to go Jade a
jade rant a jade rant there you go have
you uh have you previously named that or
um I think they got it from the Dave
rant oh I think it's a subsidiary okay
subid holy own subsidiary okay uh I
drive every morning as an Uber lift
driver in New York City I listen the
podcast with my passengers some don't
pay any attention but those that do
listen ask and become interested I share
my experience and my baby steps that I'm
at and I really enjoy getting
compliments from the other Ramsey
followers wow that get into the C get
into Uber yeah uh glad I'm not the only
listener in New York City well I'm I
love that I'm glad you're not too but
I'm glad both you found each other no
I'm kidding there's a bunch da that's
how I found you if somebody had you on
the car radio my brother had you on the
car radio well there you go forced
forced listening there you go Lara's in
Sarasota hi Laura welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi Dave how are you better than we
deserve what's
up so I have a question we're paying off
the L of our debt I have about 66,000 on
my car I just want to know do you think
I should be able to get my nails done
while I do that
I am unqualified to answer this question
as I am to answer can I get my hair done
when you uh do this so however Jade is
sitting next to me with fluorescent
Nails she is qualified ah so what Sam
and I did when we were paying off our
debt is we kind of I I did not get my
nails done and every so often I was able
to get my hair done so it was a
trade-off because it can get expensive
if you're going every two weeks and
you're doing the hair thing and you're
doing I don't know what you're getting
your eyebrows you know whatever done it
get another thing I'm inexperienced at
da you don't do you don't wax a whole
bunch of these things I don't know
anything about so the point is it's a
lot of grooming it can get expensive um
some of it it's like yeah you need
somebody to cut your hair every now and
then or you need you know whatever that
is but Nails truly is one of those
things that it is cost to get your nails
done
Laura it's about $50 each time so and
how often how often would this come
up it's every two weeks was right on the
hammer y okay all right and so I I you
know I grew up redneck hillbilly so I
don't know anything about this but when
I was growing up people did their own
Nails is that a
possibility see I work in the
professional uh industry and I have
really brittle nails and so when I don't
have them done I they look gross and
disgusting I say I wasn't say disgusting
I said I mean like I mean my my little
sister and like they would paint stuff
on there do y'all still do that I mean
do humans do that do them themselves
ever no every all the women are shaking
their head now yout like I'm from
another planet you can paint them but
she wants an application that's going to
make them hard so that they don't break
and I will say um Laura you can you can
buy the dip powder and you can do those
yourself and it is a lot less expensive
I don't do it but I have friends that do
it and that might be you do it when you
weren't getting your nails done no
because I but yours weren't brittle no
they weren't brittle or I'm learning so
much today you can even buy the jar of
like the hard gel that you can polish on
and so that's that'll save your nails
without you having to get them done
where is Rachel Cruz when I need I feel
your pain though look I feel her pain is
that's a sacrifice but it's only
temporary what's your household
income we make about 200,000 and the
66,000 on the car is the only thing we
have left but who whose car is it yours
or it's mine sell the car and yeah we
are so we are that's our plan we're
gonna sell the car obviously we're
upside down on it so we're gonna have
we're GNA take our three to six months
and pay off the difference and then I'll
get like a $20,000 car and we'll pay
that off in about three to four months
and then we'll pay the house off wait
wait a minute how much do you have in
savings we have about 15,000 in savings
and that pays off the difference when
you sell the car but then you were going
to go finance a $20,000
car
yes no I don't think I would do
that
wow okay so here here's the thing
um I mean we had a lot of fun with your
nail question and it's fine to talk
about 100 bucks here you make $200,000 a
year you got other problems than a 100
bucks so are how How Deeply do youall I
mean it feels like he cut your nails and
cut your nail budget back and he's still
buying like tools and stuff at Home
Depot or something I don't know it where
in the flip is 200,000 going that we
can't pay 66 off minus 15 which is 51 in
about four or five months why don't you
pay this car
off our our house payment is about 3,100
a month because we bought at the
height that should be
fine okay she have $36,000 a year going
out on a house payment you make
mhm
um yeah I guess that's a good question
maybe we need to sit down do you do a
budget we are going to start doing a
budget okay you don't cut you don't cut
your nails out until you guys get the
rest of this fixed yeah when you sit
down and do a budget that's going to
reveal the budget is like bloodwork it
reveals everything going on where the
money's going where the problem is and
so when you sit down do that you're
going to realize oh I've got bigger fish
to yeah nails if you want to cut that
that's fine but you're going to see all
the little things that's making
this difficult here here's the thing if
you guys have gone through your budget
together with a fine tooth comb and
you've slam dunked your
$200,000 income towards 51,000 because
you got 15,000 in the bank to throw at
this um I think you're going to find a
lot more opportunities to get your uh
get your goals hit very quickly than
your nails and the fact that your nails
were set over to the side as the issue
while you guys still haven't done the
budget um kind of makes me want to fuss
at him because he has you guys got to
get in there together and he's got to C
I'm just telling you there's some crap
he's doing that's more than those stupid
nails when you get in the budget you're
gonna find it yeah yeah there's there's
something he's that he's got that's his
little pet thing and he didn't want to
give up the gym membership while he's
making you cut your na cut cut out the
nails all that I I only know this
because I'm the guy that did that kind
of stuff so um but yeah I think when you
both have a very clear print out of
what's going on like Jade said the blood
work is done you get your every dollar
budget both of you are looking at it
both of you say we're willing to cut
deeply and then we're not going to cut
out $100 a month for this or we are
going to cut out $100 a month because
it's only for five months yeah I'll do
them myself for 5 months but you're
giving that over there up and we're not
going out to eat and we're not going on
vacation and we're not doing this and
we're not doing that and we're not doing
this if I'm giving up the nails that's a
fair statement are you guys putting a
lot into
retirement yeah so we actually did
complete dat the Financial Peace
University uh during the co time and we
paid off all of our debt and then we
made a stupid decision we bought a
stupid car and then we bought another
stupid car and we don't have piece
anymore so we're getting back into FCU
and you've still got your retirement
coming out mhm yeah and my guess is it's
quite a bit it's not just 15 is it it's
not
$50 no it's more than that I rest my
case there you go okay get back on the
detailed scorched Earth baby step two
budget the two of you together stop your
retirement use all non-retirement
funding to clear this car up you're
right it was a stupid decision yes you
fell off the wagon yes you're getting
back on the wagon but that's not we
don't go straight to the you can't get
your nails done while I put 15 % into
retirement that's right thank you hello
he he's not following our system okay
we're telling you to stop everything and
get this done and then I may cut the
nails too not cut the nails cut the nail
uh expenditure treatment out uh whatever
the flip you call it and um anyway but
that's more symbolic with your income
that you've gotten everything else going
than it is actual yeah does that make
sense and sometimes because you're
changing Behavior symbolic things
symbolic sacrifices are
valuable okay I remember I had a old boy
from the country at Financial Peace
University one time he came in big old
guy and his wife was sitting in a small
group crying and she said I love my
husband so much he just sold his knife
collection it was like his prize thing
yeah meant a lot to but he said my wife
and my kids's future means more than
those knives he said 1,100 bucks it
didn't really matter cuz they had
$60,000 in debt but it was it was
symbolic I'm that he's putting the
family before meoo this is the ramsy
[Music]
show Dave here you can find all of our
shows with the Ramsey Network app on
your smartphone it's the only place to
listen to the entire back catalog of
episodes download the Ramsey Network app
in your favorite app store today
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Jade washaw Ramsey
personality is my co-host today open
phones at
5225 you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money Derek is in Arkansas
and starts off this hour hey Derek
what's
up hey Derek or sorry hey Dave um uh
thank you for taking my call um I'll get
right to the point my wife just wrote a
New York Times bestselling book um that
released less than a month ago um we've
already started to see some income from
that uh most recently a check for
$50,000 that came in on the the date of
the release um and then I'm a longtime
listener first-time caller uh listen
ever since I was a missionary in Nepal
um my supervisors gave me your materials
over 10 years ago and just appreciate
what you do so my wife and I U were
talking about this and she recently uh
got a message from Rachel Cruz who
reached out to her to my wife and um and
just said she' read the book and uh so
my wife and I thought well you know we
really appreciate you guys and the
principles that you stand for so I
wanted to um just call in and see what
your thoughts were about what we should
do with um some of the income that we're
getting I've already maxed up my
retirement in my job um we're debt free
um we've already maxed out a raw ir raay
and didn't know if we should open a a
brokerage account um just with an S&P
index um S&P 500 Index Fund so the house
is paid off
yes sir yes sir you're 100% debt free
and
everything that's correct way to go dude
how old are
y'all I'm 34 my wife is 32 so this so
this uh 50,000 on the book is spare
change right now it's you're over and
above the baby
steps well we're on baby steps I guess
it would be five and seven um we've got
three boys uh ages one to eight so um
okay so you might want to use some of
the 50 for Education you're
saying correct have thought about that U
didn't know if we should put a certain
percentage of that toward kids college
and then uh some toward a an index fund
just to keep some liquid cash because if
we did move we would want to pay cash
for a house so if there was how much is
in your emergency
fund uh about $50,000 right now not
counting the book deal what's your
normal household
income uh fluctuates irregular um I just
graduated graduated from law school and
uh started Prosecuting r year so uh we
had uh with partial year work last year
about uh 65 uh looking at about 150 this
year and about 85 next year and that's
just my income plus a little bit of
income in addition to B my wife brings
in from social media things like that
yeah well done well played yeah I think
you got it down it's exactly what I
would do with it I would if it were me
and I had that money in your shoes I'd
probably break it into thirds and give
save spend it I'd give some of it I'd
save a third you know for your college
fund or whatever you have set up 529s
and then I'd come up with something you
guys want to do maybe you're saving for
a trip maybe it's you know a vehicle
you're saving for whatever that spinage
that you're wanting and I'd break it up
like that or maybe in fourths since
you've got two kids you put a quarter
for each of them for
Education you think just opening one
account and then um for 529 from from
Child correct for I would put a little
in I'd open three I'd put a little in
each of their names oh it's three kids
I'm sorry I said too but yeah and I the
reason I do that Derek is just so I can
tell them over and over that this is
their college fund which presupposes
that they're going to college and then
if we want to change that as they get
later in life I can not force it on them
but I just want to brainwash them that
continuous learning throughout your life
is a brilliant idea like you went back
to law school after the mission field
okay so continuous learning after after
you know the last thing you read That's
non-fiction after house school is
nothing then you're not going to grow in
life so you adding learning whatever it
is whether it's for your education or
not uh isn't there so Rachel reached out
to your wife about her New York Times
bestselling book so uh your wife is
Jill yes Jill dug duer now Dillard yeah
yeah counting the cost is the book right
yeah okay all right so the Jill Dugger
book yeah because Rachel and I were
talking about the other day and uh cuz
the book is impressive and Rachel was
saying she was going to try to get her
on the show or at least do some kind of
social media collab with her yeah okay
well I didn't know about that but that's
probably why she reached out to her yeah
because we were both she and I were
talking about your old story and your
life and everything um and um because
I'm I'm uh of course old and I remember
all that stuff uh from a thousand years
ago uh the whole goth thing and all that
stuff and then it's very interesting
it's very interesting and so um
and and then to see what you guys have
done as a couple is impressive but you
guys are really it's very cool at least
the outside looking in I I don't know
you personally obviously but um well now
I have to read the book yeah you do yeah
what' you say it was called It's called
counting the
cost a lot of it really goes into what
especially John deloney goes into
and his his influence recently has
helped us as a couple so appreciate this
wonderful thing of boundaries and
forgiveness
correct and not you know and not not
don't spend your whole life being
defined by bitterness and so on so yeah
it's pretty cool and you you're I didn't
know the part about you going back to
law school that's very impressive good
for you thank you so well done dude
decided to go back to law school through
through all of this and and the book
just came out so it hit the times in the
last few weeks
right right about two weeks ago hit the
times congratulations came on the 12
thank you yeah that's that's impressive
yeah cuz the times is not not known for
putting Christians on the on their list
so um they kind of known for not doing
it actually but yeah but right that's
I'm glad you did that's awesome man very
good very good yeah so I'm with Jade I
would go thirds uh throw some at the
kids to make sure we got the college
thing beefed up a little you're going to
have enough income to make sure they're
okay on educational choices later in
life anyway you're going to be fine um
and enjoy some of it and be generous
with some of it I'm with her give save
spin give save spin love that very cool
that's exciting very cool how do you get
on the New York Times best like how does
that work uh it's up to them has nothing
to do with actual numbers sales it's not
sales no it's an editorial list so they
decide so like it's not off it's not
unusual for one of our books to out sell
their number one yeah by by five to one
well that's what I know that's what yeah
that's pretty standard yeah basically my
rule is New York time sucks so well now
they're not going to put you on the list
they were not going to put me on anyway
I've said they suck for a long time I've
been on there a couple times been there
done that didn't help me a bit didn't
change anything no one ever no one ever
sent me a check cuz I was a New York
Times bestseller not once uh but but
because I had a bestseller I've gotten a
lot of checks because that means we sold
an actual number of books that's a
different thing that's what counts I
guess but I'm glad they got on I'm not
being not being jealous of them I'm
happy young couple with a brand new book
and and the Apparently I haven't read it
but apparently the book is good richel
was talking about it so good stuff
that's fun you never know never who's in
our audience I know this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America open phones at 8825
5225 Riley's in Raleigh North Carolina
hi Riley welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave hi Jay how you doing great
what's
up so uh I am
considering selling my condo and because
I've got some neighbors that I am not
too happy with and the housing market is
expensive in the area so I'm considering
selling my condo moving into an
apartment and using the money I make
from selling my condo to pay off my
student loans and if I did that I would
have no debt and I'm just as to whether
or not that is a good
choice so you want to sell your condo
your neighbors are kind of annoying you
don't necessarily want to be paying for
this anyway how much student loan debt
do you have it's about 88,000 what will
your condos sell
for um I think it would sell for uh
around 260 or 270 so My Equity would be
around around $100,000 okay so you owe
around 160 or 170 okay okay and what do
you make yeah yeah uh I make about 95
and how old are
you uh 32 and you're
single correct okay how long have you
had the
condo um just about exactly three years
what's wrong with the
neighbors um so they are renters they're
they're below me and um it's been a
plethora of issues over the course of
the years different different bad rers
in that same unit over the course of
three years uh smoking uh really loud
dogs that are left on their porch I live
above them the dogs that are under me
barking waking me up all night and and
uh on top of that and the the owner of
the unit and the HOA are not helpful do
you think you'd want it I'm just
wondering why is the HOA not
helpful they basically just don't do
anything yeah you make complaints and
they um you know it's it's a very
laidback HOA I would say which I guess
in some ways could be good but in in my
circumstance it's you know not helpful
yeah I okay there's a couple things
number one if you want to do your plan
that's fine
um sometimes there's a uh um sometimes
there's a time to leave and um I'm not
selling something that I own because of
renters and an HOA that won't do its job
I'm going to start jacking some people
up mhm like if the HOA got a letter from
your attorney that said we're getting
ready to sue you guys for violate for
not doing your job which is making the
rental units have renters that freaking
behave that's like the hoa's job in a
condo they don't do much else that's
what you're paying for yeah correct time
for Barney F to get his one bullet out
which is always who runs the HOA right
yeah you're right
is there anything else about the condo
that would make you want to leave other
than the neighbors um you know I would
like to you know if if it was more
affordable I would like to purchase a
home that the the situation is I bought
my condo in 2020 and the interest rates
were really low so I've got a very cheap
cond you know it's cheap to live there
right now I'm paying around 1,00 total
with the HS whereas if I want to buy
even a small home in the area you know
the interest rates are now around 7% so
I don't have really a cheap I don't have
an equivalent option right um and you
know is a small condo it's it's a place
I would not live in you know for a long
time anyway it's okay to sell Jake I'll
tell you the other problem you're going
to run into when you sell it the real
estate agent that comes over to list it
is going to smell smoke and hear barking
dogs I know I am worried about that and
they're going to they're going to say
this is going to affect your buyer
so these people have devalued your condo
by their
misbehavior yeah like it's not going to
bring as much because people aren't
going want to pay for a smoke infested
dog barking bunch of crap well that's
one reason that he needs to yeah you got
to get this cleaned up yeah this HOA
yeah yeah they they really gonna have to
stop it I mean it's it's ridiculous and
it's frustrating because it's not like
it's not 247 bad where you know I could
see an in where um because it's it's
what I've experienced where sometimes
I'll have a week where not that bad and
I feel like if there was somebody you
know a buyer looking at it they might
not notice that stuff but then there are
times when it is bad where you know I
could see both instances where a buyer
could come in there at a bad time and
say oh I'm not buying this and I can the
opposite to because I'm the one I
witness both myself but you don't want
to risk you don't want to you don't want
to gamble that you know the the open
house or you know on the week in the
open houses is the the weekend they're
throwing a rager call here's what you
can do call the um our jump on line at
Ramsey solutions.com find one of our
real estate Professionals in the area
that we endorse that are ramsy trusted
tell them when they come over to look to
call the HOA and say we're getting ready
to put this on the market and if the
renter downstairs isn't behaving I'm
going to advise my client to sue your
butt off and let the realtor play the
heavy and see if we can straighten these
renters up for 30 days and get this
thing sold
yeah yeah and then
move I I just I just have trouble
letting these people run me off without
that's it's exactly how I feel yeah I
feel like I don't like them controlling
my life you I don't you know because I
feel like I made a good purchase and you
know I have it's kind of what an HOA is
for it's so that people you know if you
want to be a if you want to raise hell
and throw parties and have barking dogs
you're supposed to go out in the country
not in a condo project hello I mean this
is not it's not rocket surgery here
people yeah all right wow amazing I know
right yeah that that's what I would do I
think you put it on the market and let
the real estate agent call the HOA and
uh tell them to um tell tell them to be
real tough on them and uh to threaten
them uh that they I want this crap
straightened up seriously I'm getting
ready to put this house on the market
and if there's condo on the market and
if this unit doesn't sell or it sells
for Less because of smoking dogs I'm
coming after y'all for the difference in
the Lost value because you didn't manage
the property like your like your job is
yes why is that these HOAs man they're
usually they dri I hate them they drive
me nuts I live in one that drives me
nuts it's just God have you ever been on
the board of one
no can I tell you that one time were you
were I'm G to blame it on Sam Sam was we
were but it was really Sam he was trying
to make a difference and they did a
while found out this yeah no it's just
God I I should I'm the guy that ought to
be on a piece of ground somewhere middle
nowhere but I'd be living by myself
because my wife ain't going to live
there so I'm stuck with these choices in
my life you so I'm I'm stuck worse than
Riley is I mean it's you know so yeah
Riley's in a pretty bad way yeah it's
bad sell it get you an apartment then
immediately start saving and get back in
the real estate market as quickly as
possibly can Riley let's not let this be
a reason you don't own a piece of
property 2 years from now so many people
are struggling with that his main
thought though which is I bought I have
such a low interest rate and I'm stuck
and now I'm just I have L people are
waiting on rates to come down to move
because of that I know and I got bad
news for you it's going to be a while
boys and girls and while you're waiting
house prices are going to go up they are
yes they are we told you that this time
last year and what we predicted is
exactly come true yeah we told you in a
real estate live stream that we did last
year at this time that rates were that
house prices were going to go up about
7% in the year 2023 and that's what
they're trending right now I mean I know
people who are sitting on the money they
could buy but they're just like uh it
like grosses them out no like to have
the right down payment but the interest
rates are just grow grossing them out
I'm like if you got a high interest rate
when the rates come down just refinance
exactly or better than that pay the
stupid thing off and get rid of the
interest rate you know I mean there
there's a couple ways around this so
yeah it it's this trying to time this
stuff but it's a generation that's never
seen High interest rates and this these
are not high interest rates by the way
you need to talk about this more often
Dave 1982 when I got out of college they
were 18% 177% fixed rate in 84 they were
down to 14% fixed rate now that's high
and so that's back when the dinosaurs
roam the Earth you Boomer yeah I know I
know I know that works right but U but I
also know what high is cuz high is all
relative six is high if you've been used
to three that's right it's relative
there you go this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
thanks for joining us America reminder
the money and marriage getaway October
19th and 21st is just a few days away
you and your spouse will be equipped
with tools to cast a vision for your
family set goals create a life you both
love uh you will have the undistracted
time to disconnect from everyday life
and
reconnect with your spouse interactive
sessions and uh all kinds of sessions
with Rachel Cruz Dr John deloney on
money communication boundaries intimacy
tickets are $799 for this multi-day
event it's here on the Ramsey campus if
you're out of debt you got room in the
budget this is a must do the money and
marriage getaway a very luxurious
weekend here on the Ramsey campus um for
couples coming up October 19th through
the 21st check it out Ramsey
solutions.com events to get your tickets
now on the debt free stage in the
headquarters ERS solution of Ramsey
Solutions here in the lobby uh Joshua
and Becca are with us hey guys how are
you good how are you better than I
deserve welcome where are you from We're
from Indianapolis Indiana all right
right how much have you paid off how
much debt $50,000 woohoo 50k and how
long did this take seven months all
right wow Jack and your range of income
during that time 83,000 83 what do you
all do for a living I'm a personal
fitness coach mhm and I work at a church
a local church oh wonderful what kind of
debt was of 50k student loans all right
whose student loans yours or hers mine
yours all right how long you'all been
married a little over a year ah so we
get married and then we pay off Joshua
student loans yes first order of
business yep tell me the story what
happened here yeah so I grew up uh and
my dad was a big big fan of yours and so
he put that in us uh since we were
little growing up and uh so when I met
Joshua and he was like I have student
debt I was like oh no and so if you
weren't cute that'd be a deal breaker I
know but he is so it worked um but and
so then we just like talked about it and
I actually like gave him your book and
he started reading it and um applying it
and so I knew that he like had the
ability like he wanted to do this as
well uh and so then well he's a personal
trainer for god sakes discipline is his
middle name right right yeah uh and so
then he got the app the uh every dollar
app and started working that and making
his own budget and I remember he texted
me one day he was like I made a budget
he like look at it I was like this is
awesome look at it
yeah so you're a keeper I know I was
like that's awesome so um we made the
budget and then um decided when we got
married that uh my father had like saved
up money and had make us like a wedding
fund and so we were like I don't really
want a super big fancy wedding and I'd
rather like not have a lot of debt so we
did we got married in my parents front
yard and it was beautiful and awesome uh
and then we took the remainder of it and
then my savings uh and then we uh he
paid his savings and we paid it off so
wow wow boom just like that I mean you
attacked it we did yeah look at you
that's a sacrifice when you know there's
money that you can have this big wedding
a big party and you say no this is more
important that's one day this is the
rest of our life yeah exactly and I
think too just um growing up like being
Believers and just like knowing that
Christ sacrificed for us of just that
like he paid our Eternal debt and so
like At first I was like I don't want to
give him like my money but then it's
like no we're married like we're one and
like this is what Christ has done for us
and so to be able to like combine that
and like be truly one and like to pay
off that debt and was really really cool
so Joshua she comes at you with all this
stuff did you go like whoa I mean at
first it was a different approach
uh so I mean my my parents did Financial
Peace growing up I have a special needs
brother so you know the whole financial
situation was a little bit different uh
so to go from that you know to this is a
completely different side of it you know
my parents did help us along the way um
but yeah I was like okay I got to do
something here I got to step up if I'm
going to be a husband I need to be a
leader and so I was like I got to make
change look at that how old are you too
I'm 27 she's 26 way to go way to go
amazing well you leaned in knocked it
out fast and that's got to feel good you
got to feel strong oh yeah both of you I
mean you did grown up stuff here I know
right was very very difficult I mean
exciting be Becca's uh not a princess
she's like a woman no she's a woman all
right thank you she's got she had a full
agenda and a full plan and made sure it
got executed that's
there's not there's not yeah that's
that's good stuff well done y'all very
well done thank thank you okay now that
you've done it uh you see the principles
of the process I mean you teach
principles when you're teaching as a as
a trainer right and uh you know we have
principles that are guiding these baby
steps are guiding this process what did
you all observe that you tell other
people here's what you do if you're
going to get out of debt you got to do
these three things or these four things
what what was the thing you think of I
think one of the big things first off is
just communication espe from two
different financial backgrounds what
that like and saying okay we're a couple
now God said we're one so we got to
figure out how we can do that to start
off so definitely starting off with
communication and then coming up with
the plan and then figuring out exactly
what we need to do with that plan and
what that step is going to take and
making sacrifices so even though I was
working as a personal trainer still have
been you know I worked at Chick-fil-A
for a little bit to earn a little extra
income on top of that in the evenings
and then uh before we got married paying
off even car loans debt and stuff like
that too and then going from there and
like okay like if we're going to attack
this we're going to attack this and get
it paid off cuz most people my age most
friends are not in this position being
in their 20s so we wanted to glorify God
along the way but understand like we
don't have to just be in debt and that's
not the not the right way to do things
not the plan you had to feel like when
the student loans started back with
payments the other day that you dodged a
bullet absolutely we did we were like
watching it while we were paying it off
and like okay they pushed it back more
okay we got to go before they put in
interest like we got to keep paying it
and like I think that was the one good
thing about the co year honestly yeah we
like thank you for that because I
remember I submitted my first payment
was $150 and then by the time we got
married I was like oh we got huge
payments here and then yeah about in
April we were like oh we're debt free
and it it felt weird it was but it was
great we're like what the heck yeah just
like that boom yeah wow I love it if you
want something different you have to do
something different and you guys
embraced that it was it's different
right to give back some of your marriage
money it's different
fore when they're you know engaged to
say you know when we get married some of
my savings is going to go to pay off
this debt like that that's all
completely different from what culture
might say you know to work a second job
in the evenings Chick-fil-A in the
evenings so you guys really did
sacrifice to win that's amazing yeah yep
well done love it proud of you thank you
I'm betting both sets of parents were
bragging on you the whole way cheering
you all oh yeah awes yeah that's great
couple of financial peace babies one
more intense than the other but there we
go I love it still very good good job
you guys very well done your future I
mean when you you can take any problem
and set it in front of you too and you
do exactly what you did here yeah you
analyze the problem and say what must be
true what have we got to do to get this
done all right lean in next thing you
know game on and you'll have these
things pop up from time to time
hopefully this one will never pop up
again but uh but you'll have other
things as you go through your life and
now you're equipped so that's the gift I
mean the getting out of debt is powerful
but the process that you use is even
more powerful yeah so working together
having a plan thank you to the every
dollar app people well done well done
good here's my budget look at it I like
that I sounded like that I did it best
text very good we've got the live and
give box for you that's the baby steps
millionaire book which is your next step
on the journey to be able to live and
give like no one else and then of course
B The Total Money Makeover you can give
that to someone else get them started
Financial Peace University if you hadn't
gone through it go through it together
if you have give it to somebody and uh
that's why we call it live and give so
enjoy well done you guys congratulations
Heroes you're Heroes man that's powerful
Joshua and Becca Indianapolis Indiana
50,000 paid off in 7 months been married
12 months did it making
83,000 count it down let's hear a debt
free Scream 3 2 1 we're Deb
free that's how that's
done I love it who
man oh man if everybody could get it
that quick Dave it'd be so much easier
oh gosh yeah yeah that's uh but that's
the good news about being second
generation Financial Peace you know
Financial Peace babies it's even if you
got a if you're a little off you still
can boom you hit it you know you know if
you hit it it'll work it's like um yeah
that's that's different hey you're doing
an every dollar webinar
tomorrow Tuesday at 11:30 that's right
for those of you listening totally free
that is the uh 20th uh no it's not it's
the 10th the 10th tomorrow at uh at
11:30 central time we're going to be
doing a few others if you want to join
the free every dooll webinar on how to
do just what he did I did a budget so
you'll be able to do it tomorrow right
that's right and everydollar.com
budgeting sign up with Jade for tomorrow
or uh Jade later or Rachel Cruz or
George camel we're doing them all
through the fall here you're going to
want to sign up and be part of that just
like he did this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
our scripture of the day Romans 13:1 let
every person be subject to the governing
authorities for there is no Authority
except from God and those that exist
have been instituted by God Milton
Freedman said if you put the federal
government in charge of the Sahara
desert in 5 years there'd be a shortage
of sand oh
gosh sheesh
Nobel prizewinning Economist by the
way oh you gotta love it Jade washaw
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
uh we are in the last day of Dr John
delon's Book Week launch uh we launched
it one week ago tomorrow his new book is
called building a non-anxious life and
it is the six daily habits uh that are
needed to do that to deal with anxiety
to prepare for when anxious things
happen your glass is full and you can
deal with them and uh this is uh this is
a lot of Neuroscience a lot of nerd
speak all boiled down where normal
people can read it like me and uh Dr
John this is a second book his first was
a number one National
bestseller um own your past change your
future building a non-anxious life has
already sold a bazillion copies in uh
the pre-sale and in the first week thank
you guys for the response to this we'll
know for sure where we land on the list
in a day or two but pretty much suspect
it'll be number one based on our based
on our sales um and normal normal book
business stuff but we'll see we'll see
we've sold a bunch of them and you guys
are we appreciate you thank you for
picking it up that you're going to be
glad you did it's worth every penny it's
a great book ramseys solutions.com you
can get it there you can get it anywhere
great books are sold Amazon Barnes &
Noble all of that building a non-anxious
Life by Dr John deloney Britney's in
Phoenix hi Britney welcome to the Ramsey
show thank you so much Dave sure what's
up so my husband and I are wondering if
we should sell our investment property
to pay off of our debt all of our debt
okay uh do you like the investment
property I love it but we have a kid on
the way and so things are changing for
us um and our income is going to
significantly drop you're going to stay
home okay your your phone's breaking up
like crazy um having trouble see if you
can get somewhere where we can hear you
but anyway so what do you
make um that we make about 125 125 what
do you make yeah I make uh 75 of
that okay what's the investment property
worth
uh 200,000 and we take home uh we net
$1300 each month on it what does it what
do you owe on
it um
we what do you owe on
it it's free and clear we don't owe
anything oh okay and what is your pro
your personal residence mortgage is how
much uh 345 currently okay and you you
have 145,000 other than this
um I'm sorry I I didn't okay you have
200 if you sell the rental you owe 345
you said pay off your house yeah do you
have other money
saved uh no we do not we' be paying off
our uh some of our other Consumer Debt
student loans and medical bills that's
$882,000 so um we would were hoping to
that L and
then to the
where did this where did this rental
property come from how'd you end up with
a paid for $200,000 house if you're this
broke so um we actually we wrapped it
into the financing of our our home
oh so our primary residence is worth
$500,000 and this invested property is
worth
$200,000 so we've
got mortgage and then $882,000
of other
debt and we're wanting to sell the
investment to pay um these the debt
consum loans and medical yes I would
sell
it yeah yeah I would sell it um you pay
off 82,000 in Consumer Debt you got a
baby on the way you $345,000 mortgage
you're getting ready to be making
$50,000 a year I'm not sure how you're
paying for a $345,000 mortgage you may
be selling your home too that's what I'm
thinking um I don't think you can
service that debt on 50 Grand unless
they I'm not sure about it but unless
they sold their existing house and moved
into the rental and then had that one
free and clear might go that way yeah
because I don't think you can I mean if
if you quit you make 75 of the 125 he's
got he's got $50,000 income paying a
payment on yeah that's G to your
payments got to be four grand
anyway and yeah you're not going to make
that your payment's going to be as much
as his income mhm yeah that's not going
to work hun they got to get out of their
existing home you can't keep the house
mhm you can't afford it so yeah we're
selling the wrong
house uh you're moving into the paid for
rental the good news is it's paid for or
you're working yeah you got to decide
but if you want to keep this house the
one you live in you're
working and you sell the rental and
payoff if you if you're working you sell
the rental and pay off all the other
debt you can probably make it it's tight
then yeah
but um but you can't make it you can't
pay the payments on this and you pay
down a little bit on the 345 and redo
the loan at a higher interest rate
you're not going to you're not going to
net anything different so there's
nothing happening here kid I'm sorry
yeah that that the house you bought you
can't afford if you want to quit and
stay home with a baby and either one's
an okay Choice with me m uh personally
I'd move into the rental and stay home
because that's your that's your heart's
desire exactly I'd rather stay home than
have the house the big house mhm uh the
house you can't afford but you can't pay
the payments on his income and if they
are living in the $200,000 house paid
for their income's freed up they can
start stacking away money they're 100%
free yeah there's more freedom there you
get to stay home you have no debt that
would be my that'd be my solu and you
start you know you start stacking cash
and then if you want to move up in house
in a few years you'll be able to do that
with cash but right you cannot afford a
payment on 345,000 making 50 Grand I'm
100% sure of that and there's not not
any numbers you gave me here unless
there's a piece that Britney didn't give
me yeah that uh that changed that if
there's a $200,000 laying somewhere else
but I didn't hear that you did ask that
because you said when she wanted to pay
off the debt for the the their existing
home you said do you have another 145
she said no so yeah we have it no we
have another 82 in consumer was our
answer yeah that's it Jay's in Tampa hey
Jay welcome to the Ramsey
Show hey Dave and Jade can you guys hear
me okay can yes better thank you how can
we help thanks thanks for taking my call
okay so I I just I'm going to hit you
with some numbers um I the main question
is uh I want to know if we should use
the check that we're expecting from the
car insurance I just got into a car
accident a few days ago and you're get
did you total
it yes did you owe money on free and
damage no free and clear we just paid it
off okay what's it
worth uh it's worth between 9 and 11 buy
another car with with
it rather than yes cuz I was going to
use it towards the IRS cuz they're
breeding down our throats right now that
could be different yeah that does change
what do you owe the KGB
for well uh before my wife and I got
married um how much is the
balance 91 almost 9,200 and you got
another car 9200 I have another car we
make 140 a year pay it off and save two
months and get your different car mhm
pay off the IRS and then save like crazy
get get those people out of your life
yeah I until you said that until you
said that I was real sure yeah like Jade
said that's a game changer okay I
thought so what I'm me squeeze in one
more question how do you I know you
normally say stop all 401K
contributions two I still do what if you
can use the 401K contributions to break
even on your taxes no no no no you don't
break break even on your taxes that's
not how taxes work you don't break even
tax deductions you save a quarter on the
dollar you don't break even you put in
$100 it saves you $25 on taxes you're
broke you can't do that you need to get
the stinking IRS paid off pile up some
cash get the emergency fund built make
sure you get you another car purchase
get all the debts cleared then build
your emergency fund well you got one out
of two not bad not bad Jade good show
today good show of the team in the booth
excellent excellent calls coming in puts
us hour the Ramsey Show in the books
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ
[Music]
Jesus hey what's up guys it's Jade if
you love the show and want a deeper dive
on your money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to ramsy
solutions.com today to sign up for our
newsletter again that's ramsy
solutions.com to sign up for our Weekly
Newsletter